[Music]
thank you
hello there I'm the Clark this is County
the cost on Al Jazeera you'll look at
the world of business and economics this
week one year after Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the West is still rolling out
sanctions against Moscow but are the
measures hurting financially and who's
paying the price
also this week from an energy crisis to
shortages of food and fertilizer the war
in Ukraine has upended the global
economy in many ways we learn how Bakers
as far as Senegal are coping
plus India's largest International
carrier seals the biggest Aviation deal
in history as it seeks to reinvent
itself but can Air India compete with
world's biggest Airlines
thank you
so then the ruble reduced to rubble and
the economy cut in half so said U.S
President Joe Biden after unprecedented
sanctions on Russia nearly a year ago
the country's banking energy and
Manufacturing sectors access to global
trade and the oligarchs they've all been
targeted in an attempt to undermine
moscow's war effort but Russia continues
to export oil and gas in the war rages
on and while the institute for
international finance predicted that
Russian economy would shrink by 15 last
year in fact it dropped by just over two
percent making weapons for the Russian
Armed Forces has kept the nation's
factories busy agriculture construction
and Hospitality sectors they all grew
according to Russian statistics but
manufacturing and Retail trade saw a
decline
or living costs in Russia have been
rising for months leaving people
struggling to pay for Essentials and
with the ruble weakening against a
dollar more tough times are expected Ali
Hashem reports now from Moscow
War sanctions and the global economic
downturn are reducing what Dasha can put
in her shopping basket to feed her
family
we began to focus more on essential
products due to the fact that prices
have risen we buy what we need no extras
because the priorities are already too
expensive for example we now eat less
fish than before
people in Moscow are paying more for
Less Dasha can only afford cheaper Goods
descent we're spending more of our
budget on groceries than before because
wages have remained the same and food
prices have risen
Western sanctions imposed on Russia have
led to Major International Brands
pulling out of the country local
companies are trying to fill the gap
last year it was possible to fill this
basket with more goods for less money
that's not the case anymore after nearly
a year of what Russia calls its special
operation in Ukraine experts are saying
the government is trying to control
prices but that doesn't seem to be
working
although property rental prices have
fallen the last year utility bills have
increased by nine percent according to
official numbers Big Data expert Sergey
trochinski says people are only buying
what they need
unfortunately the rise in prices for
essential Goods is faster than any
increase in people's income but people
are adapting to the difficult situation
they're reducing expenses not related to
essential Goods Sergey says inflation
has reached nearly 12 percent in the
last year but bread pasta and milk
prices are rising above that is
in Moscow there is an approved minimum
wage of about two hundred and eighty
dollars but it's obvious that living on
the minimum wage is quite problematic
officially Moscow says the conflict in
Ukraine is having a minimal impact on
the lives of Russians but on the ground
the reality appears very different
well I'm joined now from London by Maria
zagina she's a senior fellow at The
International Institute for strategic
studies Maria welcome to Al Jazeera so
the bottom line is the situation in
Russia is not quite as Biden said it
would be a year ago following the
sanctions but it's still a very
difficult situation for the man and the
woman on the street
absolutely we have to say that after a
year of sanctions the picture about
their effectiveness is rather mixed on
the macroeconomic level the economy has
proven to be much more resilient if we
look at the numbers of GDP it
constructed only by 2.2 percent last
year inflation unemployment and
manageably low we haven't seen any Bank
runs the financial system has stabilized
and that's the picture the Kremlin wants
you to focus on that everything is going
according to plan that the Russian
economy is strong enough to weather the
sanctions storm but that's the trick
with sanctions that it's hard to capture
them in one nice number and put it on a
slide in terms of the macroeconomic
figures we're sanctions they need time
to unfold and they have cumulative
effects across sectors because the the
companies so it's hard to give you that
number so we have to zoom in on the
design of sanctions how Russia has been
adapting to them and the role of third
countries so as time goes on the effect
of the sanctions will become more
obvious is that is that the case yes
that's the idea with sanctions that is
the need time to unfold simply because
um as we zoom in on one sector for
example the energy sector
um the EU has implemented its Oil
Embargo last December and we've seen uh
immediate impact um on the Russian
budget uh the Kremlin uh is paying now
around
160 billion euros per day in Lost
Revenue uh if we add the Embargo on
refine products that number is already
high over 260 million euros per day so
it's accumulating it doesn't mean we'll
have a shock effect that sanctions will
make Russian economy collapse but that's
the the effect which will unfold over
time but not enough to have a visible
effect on the war effort on Russia's war
effort it hasn't persuaded Putin to
reverse policy is it with sanctions it's
all about your expectations right if you
have heightened expectations that
sanctions will stop the or that's not
the case we have to be clear about the
limitations of sanctions what they can
do they can constrain Russia's abilities
to deprive the Kremlin of capital
technology and that's what we're seeing
uh with expert controls and
semiconductors with the sanctions on the
energy sector but they can't stop the
war immediately they can shape the
conditions in which this war will end
but we have to be clear and realistic
what they can do on the battlefield and
the Russian president is selling it as
an opportunity for for Russian companies
to fill the void left by those foreign
companies that left the country there
might be some short-term profits for
Russian oligars and indeed there there
is a thing that feeling of the 90s Vibe
back in town where you see Western
assets uh stranded Western assets are
being redistributed to oligarchs and new
people suddenly became became owners of
those businesses but that's a very
short-term picture long term did the
picture of the Russian economy is
radically because it's undergoing
multi-phase decoupling in terms of
Energy commercial financial and also
technological so that reallocation of
assets is only of short-term nature it's
not about the economic prosperity of the
Russian economy more sanctions now being
added will that ramp things up will that
make a difference it's not about
sanctions of massive consequences there
are areas where we can make it much more
tighter but the next sanctions package
is make it is the idea to make it more
costly more cumbersome for us to adapt
and also to widen that budget deficit
that has already emerged in December so
from the USS point of view the the idea
of sanctions is to poor structure choose
between funding its Mountain military
war effort and also sustaining its
economy and that that challenge is
becoming more tricky how to cover the
budget Gap that is widening while your
fiscal policy options are narrowing so
as the war goes on it becomes harder and
harder to to prosecute the war effort is
that the thing yes so they we have to
look also on uh we have to look at
Russia's reaction uh what they are doing
to adapt to this type of sanctions and
expert controls and here I think the
role of third countries is really key
how China will position itself whether
it will provide lethal weapons how
turkey will position it so whether it
will provide semiconductors that Russia
can't domestically produce so this is
all components that need to be in place
to have a comprehensive picture of the
effectiveness sanctions yeah and what
about the kind of the bounce back the
rebound of sanctions if you like the
effect of sanctions on other countries
it's never the intent of sanctions let's
say on Russia to hurt other economies
the whole concept of smart sanctions is
to avoid collateral damage to the
outside countries and also to spare any
unintended consequences for local
population and that has been the case
since 1990s since the Iraq War so we
can't say that sanctions as a concept is
a magic tool that can you know split
their lips collapse the economy and
avoid all of the collateral damage some
of it is just unavoidable by the sheer
complexity of sanctions that have been
put in place and we have to say Russian
sanctions are one of the most complex
now on the table so certain measures
have been put in place from the EU from
the US from the UK to make sure that
companies are not over compliant when
it's detrimental for example lots of
guidances have been issued in terms of
shipments of fertilizer or of grain but
that's not on the sanctions regime uh
also the price cap the whole idea is to
allow shipment of Russian crude and
refined products to third countries to
not not to aggravate the situation with
Rising Energy prices and food prices
all right Maria appreciate that we'll
leave it there thanks very much Maria
shagina from The International Institute
for strategic studies
thank you for having
of course the war has caused pain in
Europe too Energy prices soared after
Russia largely cut off gas to the
continent the European countries
scrambled to wean themselves off Russian
supplies to try and ease the energy
crisis diminishing household incomes and
while efforts to become carbon neutral
by 2050 have accelerated in some
countries other nations have reopened
old coal plants Natasha Butler reports
now from Eastern France
with its half-timbered homes the small
Eastern French town of muttershocks is
steeped in history but it's a community
firmly turning towards the future a
decade ago the mayor launched a project
to build a hydroelectric plant it came
online four years ago and now generates
enough electricity to power the town's
public buildings a huge asset at a time
when Energy prices are rising
energetic being self-sufficient when it
comes to energy is something everybody
wants now particularly it is prices are
high but here we certainly feel more
relaxed because our municipal buildings
are pumped by this plant so we have
barely any extra costs everything
solar panels on roofs reduce lighting
and better isolation for buildings are
all part of the mayor's plan to generate
enough electricity one day for the whole
town and since the war in Ukraine mutter
Schultz has become a model for other
communities looking to do the same
I'd like the World to Change but we
can't do it alone there has to be a
collective approach and what we're doing
in this town could be done nearly
anywhere the push for energy
Independence in this town is the sort of
project being encouraged across France
and elsewhere in the European Union as
the block accelerates its effort to
transition to Green energy because of
the war after the invasion the EU
launched emergency measures to speed up
the rollout of Renewables including wind
and solar power as part of the blocks
aim to be carbon neutral by 2050.
the war in Ukraine made us see that
Russia used energy as a weapon and was
no longer a reliable partner so we had
to launch a strategy to replace Russian
gas with Alternatives including LNG
increased Renewables and reduce our
overall consumption
it's clear that concerns over climate
change were already driving the eu's
green transition but the war in Ukraine
has injected a new sense of urgency and
an awareness that energy Independence
isn't only desirable but also a question
of security
well from wheat to vegetable oil Ukraine
and Russia are agricultural powerhouses
and major exporters to the world of
course the war has disrupted the global
flow of goods pushing the prices of food
and fertilizer to record highs in
Senegal the government is encouraging
bread makers to use local grains to keep
costs down Nicholas hack reports now
from northern Senegal
Street out of the oven a batch of
freshly baked bread wow
when Russia invaded Ukraine a year ago
bread maker Mustafa cell smelt trouble
because
war-torn Ukraine is the biggest exporter
of wheat to Africa this is excellent
this is what we're looking for Saul
wasn't going to let the shortage of the
grain stop him from making the best
possible loaf
great wheat mixed great bread
this is wheat that has been cultivated
and harvested here in Senegal that's 100
local as you can already see we find a
lot more nutritions better quality it's
much of a better bread because of the
wheat being grown locally this is Saul's
ancestral land in the Sahel region where
agronomists planted an experimental
variety of Wheats that can withstand
desert temperatures
it's incredible because at 46 degrees
Celsius wheat is growing here it's a
miracle and thanks to the crisis
everyone's interested in our research
and we have no more stalks of grains to
give out
samples of the grain are being kept in a
safe house so scientists call this a
seed bank and inside these plastic cups
are a variety of weeds from across the
world from Ukraine Syria to Mexico
scientists will grow them here in these
conditions because since Russia's
invasion of Ukraine the shortage of
wheat have governments in the region
fearful of social tension
most African countries continue to rely
on wheat Imports and food prices have
shot up after the war the U.N says 220
million people face hunger with bread
becoming unaffordable to many fragility
of our countries and the geopolitical of
hunger there is enough wheat on the
market because
information is Latin and some countries
are constantly depending on this market
now there is a shock
replacing Ukraine's Wheat by local
grains like Moringa Millet or local
wheat is not just a temporary solution
but a gradual change in the way
Senegalese consume baked goods A
desperate attempt in the face of a war
on another continent affecting millions
of people across Africa
foreign
expects India will become the third
largest market for air travel behind the
United States and China within the next
decade the country's largest
International carrier is banking on the
booming business and wants to modernize
its Fleet and expand its operations Air
India has made the biggest order of new
passenger aircraft in history worth more
than 100 billion dollars at list prices
the airline which is owned by Tata Suns
will buy 250 planes from the European
plane manufacturer Airbus and 220 from
its American rival Boeing French
president Emmanuel macron called it a
new success and an opportunity to
develop new areas of cooperation with
India and U.S President Joe Biden he
echoed the sentiment saying the Boeing
order would support more than one
million American jobs
all right let's take this on not from
Mumbai I'm joined by jagan nariana
padmanabhan jagan is practice leader and
director of transport and Logistics at
Crystal Dragon thanks for joining us
here at Al Jazeera so Air India made its
last aircraft purchased 20 years ago
it's completely upended that now will
this huge deal turn the airline around
do you think yeah also uh thanks for
having me out here pleasure to be here
with uh you your uh yes uh our India has
made a significant uh announcement in
terms of purchase of uh closer to 470 uh
aircrafts spread between Boeing and
Airbus uh yes uh also uh you know Air
India has been now uh in the last year
and a half been taken over by the data
group and I've heard it's a turnaround
strategy has been put across with uh
both full cost career uh emerging of
vistara and Air India which is going to
happen in the next 12 months or so and
the low cost uh service which will be
with the Air India Express and Air Asia
also coming into fold so a lot of
reaching which has happened uh and it's
gonna happen it's gonna play out in the
next 12 months too so uh I think it's a
great step in the right direction and
will very much pretty much suits the
ambition that they have into being a
significant player in the growing India
market and through India also to service
across the International Market as well
so the aspirations of India is quite
significant and Air India is going to be
stepping up to it and in a way yeah
so are paying the fleet in this way it
presents a huge logistical challenge
just to tell us more about that the kind
of challenges that air Indy will have
implementing this
yeah so and then in terms of the
implementation part of it the good thing
is uh they've traditionally been split
between the Boeing and the Airbus and
they have continued to do that to that
extent
um it is it is not something new for
them
um and then and so is the case for who
is that as well uh and the spirit which
has happened between both and Airbus is
about closer Boeing this won't get about
220 or uh aircraft and Airbus is going
to get 250 of them the second part is
that Air India also had some of the
Aging Fleet so they were in unnecessary
position uh or had to kind of reject
this and bring in new aircraft so it's
more necessity which foil which made
them to go for this kind of a change and
hence it will be a welcome change as far
as they are concerned right so there's a
lot of replacement going on as well is
there absolutely absolutely just put
that into perspective uh Air India you
know today has about closed on the on
the Long Haul white body part of it uh
has about 40 odd aircrafts and they have
ordered 70 of them
um so we can kind of say that much of
this would be in times of replacement of
the current uh aircraft and the other
part is that other airlines have got
pretty much new Fleet in them
um so like even in India if you were to
take Indigo the uh uh the fleet is
pretty much new and hence from a
customer experience they have been
pushed to get in uh to step themselves
up uh to get in the new aircrafts and
obviously it will add to their Logistics
and into the reduction in the free and
the fuel consumption and eventually uh
be able to be price competitive as well
so all of this ties up very well and
hence
um they are pretty much geared up to
take up such such parts of it and and
India has a history of running you know
an airline out here and hence they would
be able to kind of integrate well with
both of these uh players now air travel
we bounded pretty quickly in India after
covid why was that
in pretty quickly in comparison to the
international part of India's I think
the large part of that goes into the the
basic is more than the vaccination path
uh because we were able to kind of make
it a near mandatory for all of them and
made it also affordable and accessible
to the larger population and hence many
of them went through this early on I
mean the covert did really impact us
quite significantly in the initial uh or
up till second quarter of fy21 but then
later on it really bounced back the
industry bounced back and and you have
seen the kind of GDP growth rates and
airline travel is in a way linked to the
GDP part of it and hence uh that
correlation played out really well for
India the second part of it was also a
lot of people who had gone to their
Hometown practice of the domestic side
uh wanted to come back and offices
opened up so that led to the second part
the third one is in terms of the
domestic tourism
um that also really picked up uh in in
the last uh two quarters Jack and what
about uh from a sustainability
perspective because buying an enormous
Fleet like this is isn't exactly looking
towards a a carbon neutral future is it
yeah so sustainability is is one aspect
part of it but today from an overall
Transportation if you were to look at it
and in India uh this is significantly
still way off in in terms of our overall
Transportation so uh the kind of
migration which is happening in India
from The Villages into the uh cities is
quite significant uh so the aspirations
are far higher we are still from a per
capita perspective very low uh in terms
of uh in in in our per capita GDP and
hence all of this needs uh before we
kind of stabilize and move ahead
um so uh the other modes of Transport
that we have is is the rail and the
roads part of it in comparison into that
the population which goes by air is
fairly fairly less incomparate so about
close to 140 million uh we are a
population of 130 billion uh so you get
the context right so it's very minuscule
and hence uh going forward we still have
a long way in terms of our overall uh
Journey uh the aviation perspective and
then many of these Airlines and and how
we are able to kind of get new aircrafts
coming through will help at least in
reducing the carbon footprint uh from
the old to the new all right Dragon
we'll have to leave it there thanks very
much indeed for your perspective here on
Al Jazeera thank you thank you thanks a
lot
and that's our show for this week if
you'd like to comment on anything you've
seen you can tweet me at Nick Clark Al
Jaz please use the hashtag ajctc or just
drop us an email counting the cost at Al
jazeera.net is our address
there's more for you online at down to
zero.com CTC that will take you straight
to our page which has individual reports
links and entire episodes for you to
catch up on but that is it for this
edition of counting the cost I'm Nick
Clark from the whole team here thanks
for joining us the news is coming right
up
foreign